(audience applauding)
- Nice to meet you.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, nice to meet you.
- Oh my God.
- [Kelly] I love this.
- Thank you.
- You are so adorable right
now, your whole outfit.
And you have a gold medal around you.
That's it, that's it.
That's amazing.
Can I just feel how heavy it is?
- Yeah.
- Okay, fine, fine.
(audience laughing)
- I just wanna feel how-
- You can wear it.
It's yours.
- Oh, my God, I just wanna put it on.
(audience applauding)
I'm just gonna like...
Well, I'd like to thank my mom
for always being there for me
and for the best coach
in the world, Michael.
(laughing)
No, this is amazing.
- Thank you.
- You now got two.
You're just collecting them.
- I know.
- [Kelly] Have y'all met?
Have y'all met before?
- No, nice to meet you.
May I?
- Yeah, of course, oh-
- It's amazing.
(audience laughing)
- It's like a weird-
- It's like a thing everyone's
like, "I touched one."
- It's really heavy.
- [Kelly] It's so heavy.
- It is heavy.
It's also longer than my other one,
so every time I walk,
it smacks me in the stomach.
(audience laughing)
- But your cross to bear.
- Yeah.
- It's an amazing one to bear.
It's like awesome.
So, wait, congrats, the second one.
- Thank you.
- That's amazing.
(audience applauding)
- You are incredible.
- Thank you.
- Like, just watching you is incredible.
So, how crazy is your life right now?
Are people going nuts?
- Oh, it's honestly been pretty chill.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, but I landed and went
straight to the Super Bowl,
which was crazy.
- I was there.
- You were?
- Yeah, I was there, as well.
It was a great game,
especially at the end.
- Yeah.
- I left before it ended,
but it was so much fun.
- You left at the best part.
- I did.
- Yeah.
- You got jet lagged, though.
You were probably so tired.
- I also have a concussion, so I'm like-
- What?
- Yeah.
- Oh, my God.
Well, don't go to sleep or something.
Isn't that what they say or something?
(audience laughing)
Geez, I'm like, wait.
- Yeah.
- That seems serious.
- It was super fun, but at the end of it,
I was, like, yeah,
no, I gotta go.
(laughs)
- Wait, did you get the
concussion at the Super Bowl
or at the-
(laughs)
Okay cause I was like,
that would be the better story.
If you were like,
"I made it through the Olympics,
I was flying in the air on my snowboard,
bashed my head at the Super Bowl."
- No, my third run in the contest.
- Oh, God.
- I was going all out, yeah.
It's all good, though.
- Is it?
(laughing)
- I have this thing,
so it doesn't matter.
(audience applauding)
- That's crazy.
Do you do any winter sports?
Do you like snowboard or ski or anything?
- I ski, I ski.
And, it is, it is-
I just taught my son to do it, and so-
- [Kelly] Oh, really?
- That's like our little
boys' trip every year,
is we go skiing.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- He wants to board,
so, I'll be calling you about lessons.
- Please, please.
(audience laughing)
- I figured since we met each other now.
- Yeah, yeah, we're good, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- You've got a concussion.
You might not remember.
It's all good.
- My thing about snowboarding and skiing,
when I started, is I didn't like my legs
like being on two separate boards,
like possibly getting broke.
So, I snowboard.
I went for snowboarding,
cause I felt more comfortable
that they were on one board.
I don't know why.
Because, man, you can really
catch the front edge of that
and bash your face in.
(audience laughing)
- I've done that many times.
- Me, too.
It's hard.
I didn't do it again.
So, it was so hard,
and your thighs burn.
Anyway, congratulations.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Congratulations having thighs of steel.
Your family couldn't go to Beijing.
I know a lot of people couldn't
travel to Beijing with,
you know, everybody.
So were they like the first people you saw
when you got back?
- I actually saw my boyfriend,
and then my parents came after, yeah.
- Do they know that?
(laughing)
- Yes, they do.
- They were probably like, wait.
- They're like she probably
wants to see her boyfriend,
but, no, it was so nice to see everybody.
Like it-
- Was it hard being over there?
Like, not having anyone
there with you to like-
- Yeah.
- Or was it kind of cool cause
you got to be in the zone?
- I don't know, a little bit of both.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I think it was nice to
just kind of have my moment,
but I missed having them there.
Cause my favorite moment
at the last Olympics
was just going to the bottom
and seeing their faces and,
like, how happy everyone was.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I got that over FaceTime,
and I was, like, I just wanna hug.
- That's not the same.
- Yeah.
- Ah.
- Well, what I loved about it, though,
is your dad, actually got
you into snowboarding,
right?
- Mm-hmm.
- I loved the commercial, right, the ad?
- [Chloe] Yeah.
- Okay, so wait, let's see the commercial.
This is so cool.
(intense somber music)
- [Chloe] When I was younger,
I needed you.
Right there with me.
- La la la.
(laughing)
To feel safe.
Confident.
Like I could do anything.
(audience applauding)
- Oh, my Gosh.
You're about to be a puddle.
It's like-
It's so sweet.
- Girls, girls, girls.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Ah that's bad.
- What was his reaction?
As a parent, I would have-
I'm not even your parent, and I balled.
Like, that's so touching and so beautiful.
Was he just so excited?
- He was so excited.
Yeah, that was an amazing
piece by Proctor and Gamble.
And, I just kind of got to share our story
and what it took to get here.
- Yeah.
- And, when it came out,
it was just so moving.
And, it was just one of those things.
And, I also love Proctor
and Gamble's, like, spots.
I feel like they always made me cry.
- Yes.
I remember that.
- Yeah, like when I feel
like I needed to cry,
I would always watch, like,
one of their spots, you know.
- Yeah, you'd get a good cry.
- With the puppies, just like whatever.
- Yeah.
- And, now that I have one, I mean, yeah.
- I know, and it's so meaningful.
I love that it was real footage.
It was really, really cool.
- Yeah, it was awesome.
(audience applauding)